so that's so fun it's just so fun dude
it's fun and we're so fun you were so
fun it was really fun so isn't it fun
it's really really fun it's super fun
that's so fun that's kind of fun
super fun it's kind of fun you got all
these fun things it was super fun it's
so fun - fun show you are so fun now
we'll have fun with this yet it's super
fun it's really really fun fun that's
fun if I don't know it was fun wasn't it
so fun I mean that's gonna be fun get
some fun it's really really fun I
thought it'd just be fun it's a fun
being so fun super fun it's really
really fun I don't be fun how fun are
you it was fun that looked like the most
fun movie how fun is this that must have
been fun how fun is that
you're just all fun we just had fun this
is fun
yes that's all we wants give me
something good to eat exactly but it was
fun